factorizar 4x a la cuarta y menos 8x al
cubo y menos 2x cuadrada muy bien
entonces tenemos que encontrar el máximo
como un factor o bien el máximo factor
común de estos tres mono mios así que
déjame reescribir la expresión con un
poco más de colores 4x a la cuarta y
menos 8 x al cubo y menos 2x cuadrada 2x
cuadrada y vamos a encontrar el máximo
factor común ahora lo que hacíamos antes
era partir cada uno de los monómeros en
sus partes más simples que tenía que ver
con una factorización en primos pero
creo que ya tenemos algo de práctica en
eso así que vamos a intentar hacerlo
mentalmente vamos a empezar con la parte
numérica
cuál es el máximo número que divide a
los tres mono mios pues es 2 verdad 2
divide a 4 2 divide a 8 y 2 divide a 2 y
ya no hay ningún otro número más grande
que funcione justo porque tenemos este 2
entonces la parte numérica del máximo
factor común va a ser 2 ok ahora vamos a
la parte con x aquí tenemos un x a la
cuarta un x al cubo y un x al cuadrado
entonces la máxima potencia de x que
divide a los 3
es x al 4 2 x al cuadrado y finalmente
qué sucede con ye
bueno pues aquí tenemos y aquí tenemos
estos dos términos tienen ya pero éste
no como éste no tiene el máximo factor
común no puede tener vale entonces el
máximo factor común es igual a 2 x al
cuadrado ok entonces ahora lo que
tenemos que hacer es pensar a cada uno
de estos términos como 2 x al cuadrado
por algo más y para ver qué es ese algo
más lo voy a hacer de la siguiente
manera mira voy a reescribir este
término 4x a la cuarta y así como 12 x
al cuadrado por 4 x a la cuarta y
dividido entre 2 x al cuadrado este con
este se hace un 1 y entonces esta
expresión es la misma que ésta vale ok
repitiendo lo mismo con estos de acá
tenemos menos 2 x al cuadrado por 8 x al
cubo
y dividido entre 2 x al cuadrado este
con este se cancelan menos menos y este
último se va a ver un poco chistoso mira
es 2 x al cuadrado por 2 x al cuadrado 2
x al cuadrado dividido entre 2 x al
cuadrado incluso hasta se ve un poco
bobo verdad pero bueno ahorita va a
saber por qué estoy haciendo esto lo que
sigue ahora es ahora si ya podemos
factorizar este 2 x al cuadrado o bien
de distribuirlo por así decirlo entonces
vamos a distribuirlo aquí nos quedaría 2
x al cuadrado x y tenemos que
simplificar cada una de estas
expresiones la rosa la naranja y la azul
la sobre esta re fácil verdad estoy aquí
simplemente es un 1 entonces ahorita lo
ponemos pero vamos vamos con la rosa
aquí nos quedaría qué cosa sería 4 entre
2 es dos luego x a la cuarta entre x es
x al cuadrado entre x cuadrada verdad es
x al cuadrado luego está lleno se divide
con nada entonces simplemente nos queda
la ye muy bien esa es la parte rosa
- esta parte naranja ocho entre dos es 4
x al cubo entre x al cuadrado es x y
otra vez no se divide con nada nos
quedan ye y tenemos que restar lo que
queda de simplificación que ya dijimos
que era un 1 vale entonces aquí tenemos
la factorización de la expresión que nos
dan aquí arriba y parece ser que lo hice
un poco latoso y más o menos largo pero
justo
te quería explicar de dónde salen las
ideas para factorizar esto poco a poco
vale en realidad después cuando
hablaremos un poco más de práctica
podemos hacer la factorización un poco
más a simple vista osea allá ya que
agarras práctica puedes decir a ver
vamos a factorizar esto como lo hacemos
para factorizar pues tenemos que poner
tenemos que poner el número más grande
entonces el número más grande que divide
es 2
luego en la máxima potencia de x que
divide es x al cuadrado y la máxima
potencia de y pues éste no tiene
entonces no va a ninguna van entonces
dirías a este es el esto es lo que va
afuera y así inmediatamente vas a de
distribuirlo y para de distribuirlo es
bueno
con 34 x a la cuarta y entre 2x
cuadradas pues nos quedaría 4 entre 12
2x a la cuarta entre x cuadrada es x
cuadrada x cuadrada y aquí nos quedaría
y luego menos menos 8 x al cubo
entre 2 x al cuadrado 8 entre 2 es 4 x
al juego entre x al cuadrado es x y la
ye queda muy bien y finalmente 2 x al
cuadrado entre 2 x al cuadrado es menos
1 va entonces esto ya parece un poco
mágico es una forma bastante más rápida
pero para que veas que no es magia por
eso pasé por todos estos pasos y observa
si nos dio lo mismo y bueno también si
realizas la multiplicación y vuelves a
distribuir este 2x al cuadrado puedes
ver que en efecto estas dos expresiones
son iguales